لا يعرف الكثير عن مستواها العلمي او حتى
ماضيها وطفولتها لكنها تمتلك اسما كبيرا
في جمهوريه التشيك هو ريناتا كيلنيروفا
حيث تعرف كخيره داعمه لتعليم الاطفال
المحرومين بالاضافه لكونها اغنى سيده في
الجمهوريه بثروه تقدر بسته عشر مليارا
و700 مليون دولار فما سر هذه الثروه ولدت
ريناتا في الرابع من يوليو عام
1967 فيبراج عاصمه التشيك وبقي اسمها
بعيدا عن الاضواء الى ان حطت رحلتها في
البحث عن وظيفه في واحده من اهم المؤسسات
الاقتصاديه في البلاد هي مجموعه بي بي اف
الاستثماريه التي اسسها بيتر كيلر بعد
مسيره مهنيه شاقه بداها ببيع المستلزمات
المكتبيه في عام 1990 قبل ان يطلق في
العام التالي شركه بي بي اف مع حمله
اعلانيه كبيره لجذب المستثمرين واقناعهم
بتمويل شركته وكان هدفها الرئيسي خصخصه
الشركات المملوكه للدوله ومنها استطاع ان
يؤسس الاستثمارات كبيره وضخمه في غضون
سنوات قليله نمت شركته لتصبح اكبر شركه
تشيكيه من نوعها مع استثمارات متنوعه في
الصناعات والخدمات الماليه والاتصالات
السلكيه واللاسلكيه والاعلام والتكنولوجيا
الحيويه والعقارات والهندسه واصبحت تعمل
في اربع وعشرين دوله اخرى في ثلاث قارات
هي اوروبا واسيا وامريكا الشماليه في هذه
المجموعه وفيما كانت ريناتا تبحث عن وظيفه
وجد فيها بيتركلنر الذي كان قد انفصل عن
زوجته الاولى شريكه له فانضمت لاحدى
شركاته الفرعيه كاحد اعضاء مجلس الاداره
بين عامي
1993 و 1997
حيث قضى الملياردير الاول في التشيك نحبه
في حادث تحطم مروحيه في الاسكا فوجدت
رينات نفسها امام مسؤوليه كبيره برعايه
العائله ومجموعه زوجها التي تشكل تكتل
اقتصاديا ضخما بقيمه 44 مليار دولار مع
مصالح في الخدمات الماليه والاتصالات
والاعلام والعقارات بعد الحادثه باتت
ريناتا البالغه من العمر 54 عاما مديره
ممتلكات زوجها واصبحت تشارك عن كثب في
الاشراف على استثمارات العائله وتمثيلها
في اجتماعات الاداره ولكنها لم تتولى
مسؤولياته بالكامل حيث وظفت من يقوم بهذه
الاعمال اما الثروه التي تركها كيلنر
وراءه فكانت تكفي لجعل ريناتا الاغنى في
جمهوريه تشيك وواحده من النساء الاكثر
نفوذا على مستوى البلاد